实现欲望。
然后最后一个正价值负加值，这里正义战胜邪恶。
唱门是啥？
门其实我昨天说过，就是你如果不讲故事，单说你这个正负价值的较量，把你这个主题说一遍，别人有点想笑你。
就是最俗的那些词儿，你给我把它写出来。
他就是最好的主题，什么正义。
母爱。
对吧。
善良。
还有些什么词来着？
救赎。
真理。
你看啊。
这些词你单拿出来一个都不太露脸。
对于年轻的时候的。
人来说，我年轻的时候。
我也觉得觉得这些词儿就说人家问你哎，你在写一个关于什么故事，你说我想写一个关于真理的故事，你就会觉得我这个故事好像就是要不别写了吧，对吧？因为年轻人啊总有点叛逆，总想写，我得写个邪恶的故事啊，我干嘛写一个真理的故事，不是这样。
你的主题。
你的正价值必须是这些。
从来没有动摇过的。
正义的词汇。
最基本的这些去套，好吧。
那么我们。
你看啊。
我们现在这个八要素。
我们说这是故这是书上讲的八要素，这是我们根据书上八要素写了一个完整的故事。但是我们现在觉得不精彩。
那么我给大家讲了实战当中。
八要素的修改方式，我们来每一个。
都来对一下好不好？来。
警察。
我们说警察的附加值，我们前面举了一个例子，邪恶。
但是这个太。
太直白了。
太惯性思维了。
还有什么附加值？
我们说一个胆小如鼠的警察。
这也算是一个附加值。
那他在执行各种任务时候很不方便呀。
一个胆小如鼠的刑径，比如说。
重案组的。
那么他就开始有点。
附加值的意思想想还有什么。
在这里我给大家说一下啊。
这些东西其实都哪来的？
积累来了。
我给大家分享一个，我迄今为止，我认为警察的定语当中，我们说我们你看啊这叫定语，就是说给你的主角加一个定语嘛。
我迄今为止看过的最棒的一个定语。
警察的是什么？
一个。
迫切想要。
殉职的警察。
想要殉职。
殉职殉职的殉是怎么写呢？
好像是个双立人是吧？
哎，不对呀。
殉职的殉怎么写呢？
那我们就换个词吧，想要牺牲好不好？
一个迫切想要牺牲的警察。
这个定语啊。
他不是警察的附加值吧。
他他妈是人的附加值。
明白这个意思吧？这个定义一出，我们说你主角的定语，你要怎么你你要怎么着来着？说给你朋友听你拍他女朋友，哎，哥们，我给你讲一个天天想着因公殉职，想牺牲的警察，他马上问为什么？为什么？
为什么？
牺牲牺牲不是挺简单的嘛？上路让车撞死啊，是吧？就马上他就提起了他的兴趣。
对不对？一个迫切想要牺牲的警察马上提起了你朋友兴趣，这个是一个非常成功的定语。这个想死，那肯定是个附加值呀。我们说求生是。
是基本价值。
想死，那肯定是人的附加值都是。
他肯定是吸引人的。
我们说那这个第一个任务就完成的很漂亮。
对吧一个迫切想要牺牲的警察。
呃合理性呀。
我们说如果是我们只是想。
吸引别人的注意力，那没边了。
那没边儿了。
我们说哎。
我给你讲一个。
2.36米。
400多斤。
上山是人。
下身是狗，长着一双翅膀。
的警察的故事。
你朋友是一定会抬头的，但也不可能是要揍你对吧？你不能说为了让别人抬头，把前面这个定语搞得过于。
离奇。
那就不行了，那就失去了一个可信度的问题，失去可信度就失去了共情了。
好吧，就是说主角我们说主角肩负的，我们虽然给他这么分解，那么分解，但是你别忘了主角的作用了。主角是视角人物，他带着你看故事，他带着你经历整个故事，他的第一要物还是共情，让你。
跟他产生共情才是他的第一要物。你不能说我为了让我的主角啊让人一下就记住，我给那前面加的定语天马行空。
那也不行，所以是在合理范围内加的这个定义。
我们说一个迫切想要牺牲的警察，我们需要把它合理化。
啥样的死警察死瞎。
既然要迫切牺牲。
我们得给他找一个。
他现在缺乏共情嘛，因为咱们绝大部分人是不想要牺牲的。
我们想要活着呀，那什么样的人想要牺牲呢？
我们可以设定一个。
他失去了某个人。
他在悲哀当中。
失去了谁呢？
肯定是至亲的人。
至亲的人有3个。
老妈。
老婆女儿。
都是女的。
没有人会因为他爹死了，所以想不开的，至少在故事里面不可以是这样，男主角必须得是母亲。
老婆。
女儿。
儿子都很少。
按道理，儿子跟女儿是一模一样的。但是在戏里，你去看一下英雄，戏里面凡是男男人是个硬汉，是个英雄。
都是救女儿。
不救儿子的好吧，这这种这种都属于无耻的小规律，我们该用也得用，就像就像超市呃，卖东西9.9块呃，19.9块29.9块，你不知道那就是30吗？但是19.9块就是会让你舒服。
就是无耻的小伎俩。
所以我们这里来失去了谁？
我们说失去了女儿肯定是力度最大。
产生共情最最好的。
一个失去了女儿的警察。
那失去了女儿，他就难过到想要牺牲吗？
我们把它合理化一下。
他作为一个警察。
他的责任是保护。
它的属性是保护。
他保护了很多人。
但是有一天女儿。
比如说上在上高中了。
上补习班晚上很晚。
他应该去接他女儿。
他可能因为工作。
坚守岗位。
就没去。
然后女儿让人奸杀了。
他。
作为一个父亲失职了。
他没有保护到女儿。
所以他女儿现在。
而且我们故事前几分钟会。
通过一些细节交代。
呃，女儿生前是个非常乖巧的孩子。
非常听话，就像天使一样。
就像天使一样。
那他就会觉得。
他女儿在天堂上。
对吧。
他想要继续去保护他的女儿。
因为他这一生没有尽到责任。
所以他想要去保护他女儿。
那你说他可以自杀呀。
42人上不了天。
自杀人要下地狱的。
对吧我们说那。
他作为一个警察。
他想快速的去见到他女儿。
他唯一能做的就是因公殉旨。
他有牺牲。
而且我们也可以。
交代这个警察的前使，他之前可能不是一个什么特别好的警察。
并不是很称职。比如说。
所以他现在一定要因公训斥。
才能确保自己。
见到女儿去保护他。
那现在。
这个警察的形象。
完整。
隔离。
还有附加值的定。
让你的朋友抬头。
想听。
对吧。
我们说那这样一个警察。
迫切采要因公殉职的警察。
他的欲望是？
欲望是保护你。
他想去保护女儿啊。
欲望是保护女儿。
我们来检验一下，这怎么检验来着？
欲望怎么解下来着？
嘿嘿对吧？又去找那个猴子。
你说保护女儿他他能听懂吗？
你去逗一下他女儿试试。
动物园有个猴子抱着孩子，你去动一下试试。
他挠他妈死你。
对吧那当然这是猴子听得懂的欲望，一点问题都没有知道吗？保护女儿。
动作。
怎么保护女儿？
寻死。
动作坏掉了啊。
学死。
问题呢？
能不能死啥时候死，死在谁手里？
你这个戏这个人物我们说我们前三部。
完成了一个人物了吧。
一个迫切想要牺牲自己的警察。
为了。
尽快的到天堂见到自己的女儿。
到处寻死。
想要因公殉职啊，所以。
这边。
他可能是是是是个呃普通的这个这个，比如说是个交警，还是啊咱这儿不行，交警不行，比如说他是个普通的一个片儿警，对吧？听那边说，哎呦，有个人身上绑着炸弹要要怎么着怎么着在什么地铁站跟他没有关系，他去了。
对吧所有人在那布置呢，公安局怎么那个局长也来了，拿着大喇叭在就能狙击手哪哪人在都在那指挥呢，他穿着一个警服，身上可能还掏着黄色的那个那种背心咣咣咣就上去了，上去走到就歹徒面前，对吧？那警察其他警察都懵了，这他妈哪部门的？
这哪个部门的对吧？
韩判专家还在那儿呃那个那个我是来帮你的。
然后他就上去了。
结果上去捅咕捅咕那歹徒捅咕捅咕那歹徒歹徒歹徒被他整蒙了，觉得还有这么这警察是要干什么？歹徒缴械投降。
到处寻习。
核心问题就是他死不死，就是说关于呃死不死啥时候死，怎么死的问题。
我说核心问题。
核心问题我前面强调的是核心问题怎么加强？
就是悬念不断。
对吧。
悬念不断。
讲到这里啊。
我们其实这个故事的主题已经差不多出来了。
对吧。
这个故事是咱们今天临时现编的，我上课前临时琢磨的啊，所以咱们来一块创作，不用不用怕出错。就说一个迫切想死的警察为了保护女儿。
为了上天堂保护女儿。
呃到处寻死。那么他的核心问题就是他啥时候死还怎么死。
能不能死的问题。
那么这个悬念。
我说。
这个悬念不能断。
其实讲到这里啊，基本上我们主题差不多出来了。
主题会是什么？你知道吗？
主题其实是活着更好。
就是你活着。
有可能你活着才是你女儿更想看到的。
你活着帮助更多的人。
还是你女儿。
最大的慰藉，你就你在社会上当一个好警察，你能拯救更多的女儿。
你一个人失去了女儿，你不要让所有人失去女儿。
主题基本上就是往是这个。
路先生走了。
对吧非常的正能量，非常的符合我们前面说的。
要主题单说出来的话，要非常的。
牙签非常的足。
就是你活着人活着才更有价值。
你作为一个警察，你应该守护更多的女儿。
而不是守护你死了的那个女儿，这是多么正能量的，就让我都感动的快哭了这种能量，对吧？
我们说这个主题我们可以提前揭晓了，就是活着。
就是活着更好。
守护。
更多。
女儿。
这个主题出来以后啊，我们说那这个悬念不能断。
这个悬念当中。
就可以一分为二。
就可以一分为二，这个悬念就可以一分为二。
前半段是他想死了。
死不了。
想死死不了是前半段，后半段是。
想活活不了。
事情进展到一半的时候。
他蜕变了。
他发现。
连环强奸。
他女儿怎么死？
也是被奸杀的呀。
连环抢劫。
又有很多。
跟女儿一样年纪的。
小女孩。
遇害了。
三个、4个、5个接来发现。
在这件事情面前。
强烈的刺激了他。
在这种事情面前，他不会想学死的。
或者说他不会现想一死了之的，他至少要跟这个歹徒同归于尽吧。
所以在这里，他卷入了这个案子。
但是这个凶手无比凶大。
这个对手无比凶残。
他又出现了想活活不了的。
所以说关于他死不死，什么时候死，这个悬念不能断，同学们不能断，不是说我们这里触发他。
前面一直寻死，这里就变成我要探案，对吧？我就变成一个警察了，成天在那观察证据分析，然后用脑子分析，觉得嗯差不多了，就破案了不行。
不行。
核心问题还是生死。
还是生死。
就是他前面陷的太深。
对吧比如说他一直寻死不要命。
随便说啊，他他他他上次给他把枪没收了。
那这时候他其实是在这个时候已经想活了，但他没枪了。
反而处于被动，就是他前面一直血死，埋下了祸根，影响到了他后面。
开始想活。
就是这个故事转交是在这儿的。
好吧。
主力。
我们说环境的阻力，对手的阻力，自己的阻力。
我们通过这个设定非常明确了。
非常明确了，环境当然有阻力了，他想死的时候，环境不让他死。
各种立功。
对吧。
哎，一个不一个想一个天天想殉想殉职，想牺牲的警察在警队，我觉得他只要一天没死，在警队就是风云人物。
天天立功，所以环境对他很不友好，对于他想死之这件事情很不友好。哎，这还符合咱们的。
审查他还说别还能过，对吧？然后他的对手呢开始是同同僚，天天看着他。
啊，不让他出任务，有任务我也不告诉他，后来呢就变成那些歹徒，开始是些小歹徒，都都知道他不要命。
他的这个片区治安层层的往上上，犯罪率益为0，消零犯罪。
然后最后是那个。
最终的那个。
那个坏人他的对手。
然后他自己是自己的对手这件事情在这个如此分裂的角色里面是很容易做的。
对吧。
他自己到底是活还是死，对女儿的那种思念，那种愧疚。
那时候觉得自己配不配当一个爹。
配不配当一个警察，配不配活在世上，他与自己的抗争与自己的冲突是非常大的。
所以说。
主力。
毫无问题，这个人的阻力相当大。
结果呢。
我们说绕过动作。
实现欲望，我们动作欲望换掉了。
绕过动作。
动作是垂死。
欲望是保护女儿。
我么说了？
活着。
才能守护。
更多的女儿。
不就是绕过了动作。
实现了愿望。
活着。
才能守护更多的女儿。
那现在这个故事。
是不是瞬间逼格高了？
瞬间逼格高了。
一个。
想要殉职的警察。
因为女女因为女儿遇害。
轻生。
但是想自我殉职。
想上天堂去保护女儿。
寻死而不得。
反而因为过分英勇。
在警察。
这个。
圈子里面。
嗷嗷升职。
然后调进了刑警队。
从一个普通的交警，比如说调进了刑警队。
开始能接触到刑事案件。
接触刑事案件本来以为。
那这里都是武刀弄枪的。
寻死似乎更容易了。
死亡离他更近了，他的目标快实现了。
但是。
在刑事案件翻看档案。
发现了。
有很多。
跟他女儿。
一样。
在花季年华被人杀害的小女孩。
可以就是想起了他的女儿。
他不光是一个父亲啊。
他还是个警察。
而且还现在还是个刑警。
所以似乎。
他被触动了。
可以是被某个。
刚刚死掉的小女孩。
或者是某个小女孩的。
爸爸妈妈。
醍醐冠例。
还破案。
反正他又。
反正他又不怕死。
然后我又在刑警队，那我就破案呀。
但是破案过程中。
等他真的要做一个好警察的时候。
不是原本的。
他就不是原本那个不怕死的他。
他反而就出现了。
活的困难。
他之前是想死不能死。
发现这是想活。
怎没也说到过这些。
然后最后。
体现的主题就是。
活着更好。
能守护更多的。
我这个故事。
逼哥。
立刻就高了，而且具有一定的可看性。
就不用改现在这样写下来。
开一个网大。
是足足足够有余。
拍一个电影不好说。
有些同学说啊说那。
像这样一个，我们说那咱们今天就相当于实战实操，把8个元素穿了一穿。但是你这个故事没有结局啊。
那最后是怎么样呢？
他死了。
还是他活了。
他他他最后结局是什么？
我跟同学们说啊。
结局。
像这种故事。
我们说到这儿。
主题已经实现了。
结局反而是赠送的。
结局其实不重要的。
我们我们随便给他装几个结局啊。
还是这个警察，就是这个警察。
他结局是什么？
也先说一个最俗的。
他说一个岁。
他侦破了。
这个连环。
强奸案。
帮。
他看到的这些。
小女孩儿。
报了仇。
也拯救了后面小女孩的生命。
很圆满的解。
同时。
他发现。
自己的女儿也是死于这人。
这就是。
这就是一种结局，这是结局一。
没地方写了，这就差了啊。
我们说来结局一。
凶手。
也是他搞掉了这个凶手。
既是他的对手，又是杀害他女儿的凶手。
这就等于是一个。
呃，一件。
这是个键啊。
一键。
双雕。
这是个雕，一箭双雕的一个结局。
对吧那这是第一种结局。
这种结局呢。
就是一个爽片。
片。
就他最后把这个坏人终于绳之以法了，而且这个坏人他当然不用是最后发现啊，他可以在。
他可以是半路发现。
但也别发现太早发现太早纯成了报四仇了。
最好是他决定帮助这些女孩，然后在这个过程中发现。
他还我女儿也是他害的，那就愁上加愁，等于他本身的动机本身的转变是主动的。
然后再到这里，等于一箭双雕是白捡的。
这种片子属于爽片。
就相当商业了，就是因为商业呃商业片不是贬义词啊，同学们。
我说的结局不重要，纯赠送，所以人家赠送你什么都都都可以，你就得着就行了。
赠送这种结局的话就是爽片，让你高兴高兴，其实就是让你高兴高兴，让你让你痛快出一口气儿。
我把女儿也报仇了，痛快出一口气儿，爽篇好吧，就比较商商业。
第二呢。
就是。
抓到了这个凶手。
那凶手就是个凶手。
对吧跟他女儿没有关系。
那这其这就是个正常结局，对吧？
这就是个正常结局。
还有。
一种。
抓到了这个凶手。
拯救了。
这个凶手不是奸杀豆蔻年华的小女孩吗？她手里手里等于有一个。
就是。
就是他抓到这个凶手的时候，同在这个凶手家里拯救了最后一个行将。
遇害的小女孩，等于这个小女孩的命是他赐给她的。
拯救了一个小女孩。
然后呢，这个小女孩。
有个单亲妈妈。
他为什么之前一直寻死呢？
更多的原因其实是孤独。
他如果不是。
自己拉扯这个女儿。
他如果有有有太太的话，他相信他不会。
不会做这个事情，对吧？所以他其实是那种孤独。
带来的。
更大的一个伤痛来自于孤独。
所以说呢这个小女孩有个妈妈。
对吧那等于是什么呢？这个小女孩相当于她女儿的。
然后这个小女孩的妈妈跟他对个眼啊什么的，当然你不能说结尾两个人就搂着亲上的那不会的那没有那种片子，就是就是那个那个比如说这个母亲呃喊这个羞涩的邀请他来家里。
吃个饭啊。
对吧。
你观众就懂了。
就是小女孩的妈妈给就是等于是她最后救赎的对象。
完整了他。
对吧。
这种片呢。
这就叫烂片，也不叫烂片啊，就是就是有点。
有点矫情。
也不是不可以啊，不是真的贬义啊，那咱就不写烂片了，如这这么写不好。
别这么说人家。
就也是一种方式。
就会让你。
就可以让你是另外一种的爽片吧。
对吧那个拯救的这个女孩和她妈妈完整了这个。
完整的完整了这个这个这个警察这个主角对吧？这个主角。
呃，完整的他的人生。
填补了他的。
空虚。
这又是一种。
第四种呢。
就是。
他抓到了最后这个穷凶极恶的凶手。
但同时。
同归于尽。
啊这种片子呢？
这就叫黑色幽默。
有点讽刺。
就是什么呢？想死的时候死不了。
不想死的时候？
或者说。
也算四点起所。
这起所就是跟凶手。
宏位遇见。
当然还有比这更极端的。
呃，黑色幽默同归于见，就是这个最大的凶手他干掉了。
拿下了没问题，而且立功了啊啊终于那个觉得自己办了一件人事儿，办了一件人应该干的事儿，办了一件父亲应该干的事，办了一件警察干的该干的事儿。但是在他之前，他不是有几次寻死未遂嘛？得罪的一个小痞子，一个非常不起眼的小瘪三，在最后。
给他弄死了。
这就叫。
有病的编剧编的黑色幽默。
也不是不可以，就是说回到最初，你不是想死吗？给你。
好吧，我这我说结局就是想告诉大家，结局其实在这个片子里面已经不影响主题大局了。
已经不影响主题打局了。
随便装一个，看你喜好，这算赠送的对吧？
但我们的故事主体。
细化下细化一下的话，也就够拍了。
这节课就是我说的，咱们把上节课理论上的八要素。
做一个实战应用。
现在同学们应该比较明确了，记住我今天说的这些。
每一个要素。
增加烈度的。
方法和口诀。
好吧。
下课。